bonsoir camille bonsoir merci quand il
est alors vous êtes une amie de pernès
détient avec lui le soir de psg nantes
c'est ça
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce soir là
parce que vous n'avez pas que vous
l'aviez pas que vous n'avez pas quitté
d'une semelle euh non pas du tout faire
les mois plus tôt dans le salon d'un
spectacle des amis et les dodos et
devienne mon ami qui l'a vu arriver dans
le couloir oui allons donc je suis allé
le voir à l'entrée fallu de récupérer a
lancé il a dit bonjour aux gars de la
sécurité à l'hôtel qui lui a demandé de
prendre son poignet pour mettre le
bracelet et après les rentrées avec pas
il en fallait une heure dans le salon
avant le match des sisters et les cas si
tout ne vous voyez deux cas l'hôtesse il
s'agit pas du tout
[Musique]
d'accord
vous vous fier donc vous avez mon avérée
ou vous l'avez pas du tout vu avoir un
comportement déplacé avec une hôtesse
non pas du tout surtout que les hôtels
ne sont pas dans ce vallon d'accord donc
il était tout le temps à vie et on
discutait ya de bien avec nous dans ce
cas rien eu pendant une heure
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui kelly provident
avait décidé de témoigner et nous
raconter l'histoire n'a pas que des
enquêtes conduites de planète depuis la
whey et que je sache ou qui étaient avec
lui toute la soirée de 16h de qualité
9h45 je ne comprends pas quelque part je
suis en colère je le comprends pas
d'accord oui gilles week amis pendant
toute la soirée aucune des quatre
hôtesses n'est venu se plaindre ou d'un
on a manifesté une quelconque
réprobation aux instituts de supposées
de pierre ménès
aucune est devenue la loi aucune est
venu parler et maintenant des faits dans
les gradins dans le mac personne n'est
venu nous voir ni le voir
vous l'avez eue hier tout le temps avec
nous vous l'avez pas minutes gamine tout
l'été avec lui permettait aux toilettes
est d'accord hoyé guillaud moi j'ai eu
pire menace hier soir qu'il m'a donné sa
version des faits donc il évoque deux
hôtesses qui est effectivement pas dans
le salon mais devant le salon il dit
qu'il a eu à 2.4 alors avec en fait il
ya plusieurs hôtesses et plusieurs
salons avoir quatre sur deux salons le
premier contact c'est lorsque l'hôtesse
lui a mis un bracelet comme les bras
c'est pour rentrer dans un carré viiip
il aurait fait une petite blague selon
lui leur ai dit attention ne cliquez pas
mes bijoux de jeu autour du poignet et
il dit à ce moment-là je l'ait peut-être
effleuré il parle en aucun cas on aurait
caché la voilà donc ça c'est le premier
contact le deuxième contact c'est en
partant les hôtesses remettre des petits
cadeaux d'invités également dit merci au
revoir donc pas de contact il insiste
sur le fait qu'il ne s'est jamais
retrouvé seul avec les filles et que
c'est simple un tissu de mensonges selon
lui selon lui à quelqu'un qui lui en
veut qui veulent faire tomber et que
l'anc est dure depuis dix jours et que
personne ne l'a contacté en tout cas de
la police dont qui l'attend s'il ya un
sacré pavé
confirme la réalité tout seul
l'enquêté toujours invaincus